if you want to try Ghost Recon wildlands  before you buy you're in luck I'm Tony  in this game spot news update is in beta  Ghost Recon wildlands will be getting an  open beta quote next quarter this was  confirmed by Ubisoft CEO ye've Gil mall  during an earnings call next quarter  isn't very specific but considering the  game releases and mid-march the beta  will likely be held in January or  februari no details about the betas  contents were given but since Ubisoft  wants people to know what the game is  all about you can probably expect at  least one full infiltration mission with  your friends Ghost Recon wildlands comes  to ps4 xbox one and pc on march seven  2017 that's a few months out so don't be  surprised to see more trailers and info  before too long we'll post it all at  gamespot and for all the latest on ghost  recon you're already in the right place  you